foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror it's my book review series now as
you guys might remember
I had actually read quite enjoyed and
reviewed a 2019 kind of sci-fi-ish
horror novel which was called intercepts
by TJ Payne not too long ago I feel like
it was maybe last month or the month
before that
so when the same author TJ Payne when
their follow-up book which is called the
venue a wedding novel uh came out in
2020 popped up in my Kindle unlimited
recommendations that I love so much uh I
was immediately kind of intrigued by the
whole thing the cover is like really
really cool it's very very Stark it's
very eye-catching like with this black
and white checkered floor and a
chandelier like with blood on the floor
and everything and I did actually read
like a brief synopsis like it was a
sentence or two and it kind of made the
story sound something like that 2019
kind of black comedy horror film Ready
or Not which I really really liked a lot
and I was like oh that sounds like a fun
time so I dove right into this book The
Venue and ended up reading the entire
296 page novel in a single sitting like
in a single afternoon
so this book is just fun brutal gory
blackly hilarious like it has like a
really dark sense of humor and it's just
like really really action-packed and I
had an absolute blast with it
um now the premise of it is kind of
outlandish but that's kind of part of
what makes it like such a [ __ ] hoot
yes it is kind of similar to Ready or
Not Like sort of and also has some
shades of some stuff like Battle Royale
or maybe like The Purge so if that
sounds like something that you would be
into then this is an easy recommendation
like I said I had a [ __ ] blast with
this one it was just it was just so much
fun so in the prologue of the venue
we're kind of inside the mind of this
dude named Caleb and he's trying to
compose an invitation email to somebody
named Amy like he's trying to invite her
to his wedding
now it's kind of clear from his multiple
drafts uh that he and Amy used to be
best friends that uh they drifted apart
at some point like maybe when they
became teenagers or whatever that he
still is maybe kind of carrying a torch
for her and also that he has a lot of
resentment and maybe even uh despises
her for the way that he imagines that
she treated him so there's that kind of
thing we then jump to someone who's only
ever referred to as the event planner
it's just like this woman you never find
out her name or anything like that
um and she's at the venue like obviously
getting the place up to Snuff for what
you're assuming is the upcoming uh
nuptials that you know that Caleb was
inviting Amy to now the event planner in
a very nice little bit of um kind of
foreshadowing I guess uh the event
planner notices something on the ground
which turns out to be a severed human
ear very very blue velvet I liked that
little homage there so she's just kind
of like like very irritated by the whole
thing uh Scoops the ear up as you would
and Tucks it away into a staff member's
pocket uh before the arrival of the
happy couple who are Caleb and his uh
wife to be whose name is Lilith so the
event planner then escorts uh the pair
of them into the office to kind of
finalize the plans for their big day so
we then cut to Amy who seems to be I
don't know if I'd necessarily she's
having a hard time but she's kind of
like obviously at a big Crossroads in
her life so she's just broken up with
her longtime girlfriend Mariko
and even though the two women are still
friends Amy has decided to move out and
like move into a studio apartment on her
own like in order to get some space she
doesn't and you know the way that she
talks about the apartment she's it's
obvious she doesn't really have a lot of
money she's like a yoga and dance
instructor uh so she's not rolling in
Loot and a lot of the furniture and
stuff would belong to her girlfriend so
she's kind of having to restock this
tiny little place and she's like man
it's kind of sad but whatever now she
was invited to Caleb's wedding like
months before maybe even a year before
because I think they say something about
like they need a year to plan or
something like that and her and Mariko
uh you know who were still together then
when they got the invite are still
planning to go to the wedding together
because like I said they're still
friends now Amy's parents whose names
are Roger and Candace are also invited
because Caleb like grew up like as a kid
across the street from them so he knew
the entire family so they don't think
it's that strange that he like invited
uh her parents as well now the wedding
is a really really fancy like
destination shindig right all expenses
paid by the couple like the flights
every like Transportation everything uh
accommodations and the whole nine yards
neither so honestly like Amy Mariko and
her parents they're like well like a
free vacation like all expenses paid
yeah sign me up you know what I mean
um you know it's gonna be like this big
luxurious whatever and they're just like
yeah awesome you'd be stupid to like
turn that down right but I mean they
think it's a little bit weird because
they're like look we haven't even like
really talked to Caleb like in a really
long time and they're not really sure
like why he would invite them to the
event but they're like well hell maybe
he's just inviting everybody and you
know Amy was like well we were best
friends when we were kids so maybe it's
not that weird but they're also a little
weirded out by the fact that the
location of the wedding is not disclosed
all they know is that it's somewhere in
Europe and that a limo will come like on
the day before and pick them up and then
like from then on everything will be
taken care of like all of their trans
deportation there's gonna be like a
private plane and all this other kind of
stuff so they think it's like really
weird oh and another thing too is that
like the email invite they got like it
erases itself like after like a day or
two because Amy tries to go in there and
find the original one and she can't find
it anymore and it's like basically you
go to this weird website to like RSVP
and it basically says okay like we're
gonna and then you know what I mean and
then it like it doesn't really tell you
any information so they're like that's a
little odd but whatever like I said free
European Vacation they're here for it so
after traveling for many many hours uh
the four of them arrive at the venue
which is this really breathtaking spread
I think it's somewhere in the Alps
um it seems I think it's maybe
Switzerland or something like that
um so lots of the other wedding guests
are already there
and Amy like when she's in the lobby
like they're doing the check-in and
everything and she recognizes a few of
them like in particular she recognized
like a couple of teachers from the
school that her and Caleb went to like
when they were kids and we're talking
like Elementary School type thing and
um Amy thinks this is a little bit weird
she's like why would she why would he be
inviting like our third grade teacher
who I thought he didn't like her and all
this other kind of stuff also a little
bit of a red flag that all the guests
are actually asked to surrender all of
their electronic devices no cell phones
no tablets no anything one they check in
you know the venue is like that's the
rules it's like our our whole thing is
like we really value our privacy and we
really value the exclusivity of this
place like it's this big like luxury
resort it's like we don't want any
pictures of it leaking out we don't want
anyone knowing what the location is
because it's supposed to be really
private that's what people pay for and
you know they're just like and we think
that you guys will have a better time if
you you know surrender to like obviously
we'll keep them all locked up for you
and you'll get them back like after the
wedding and blah blah blah now a couple
people protest but
you know they're just kind of like well
what are you gonna do that's the rules
and the thing about it too is that it's
easy to kind of like look past that
because they give everybody like this
electronic wristband type thing that you
know opens their room and all that kind
of stuff like hotel room and it also
gives them full access to all of the
venue's amenities of which there are
many and it's all like top of the line
like luxury stuff all the food is free
all the booze is free there's
um you know swimming pools and day spas
and movie theaters and you can just
wander all around this huge complex and
do whatever you want to like on the day
before the wedding and it's just like
everything is free everything is done
for you all you have to do is like ask
and they'll give it to you which of
course uh seems too good to be true and
indeed it is
when the time of the wedding arrives
they have the wedding like in this
little chapel type thing so Caleb and
Lilith are getting married and they
wrote their own vows and uh there's
something else like they're pretty
[ __ ] weird and everyone's just like
watching this wedding going okay like uh
some of the [ __ ] they say was like
really really weird and they seem to
like a lot of their uh vows seem to be
like mostly talking about you know yes
how they found each other and stuff but
they're also talking about like how
aggrieved they are like how everybody
like [ __ ] on them and now we have all
this money and blah blah so it's just
that kind of thing and it's just like
really weird it makes everybody
uncomfortable so then like after the
ceremony is over like all the guests go
into the ballroom for the reception now
they go in there and it's like in this
just looks like a regular big Ballroom
obviously that's set up for a wedding
except on one wall uh ours is mounted
like all of these very very sharp
looking medieval style bladed weapons
which is again a little bit weird
so as should be evident by now
Caleb and Lilith have essentially spared
no expense
uh in order to get everybody here to The
Venue everybody that they feel that has
wronged them in their lives in any way
now it's not necessarily to kill them
because that would be like too easy
what they actually want to do these two
psychos they actually want the guests to
kill each other uh to what to to watch
them become like the monsters that Caleb
and Lilith have always perceived them as
like in their crazy delusional Minds so
this just like I said it's a fantastic
fantastic setup and once the gloves come
off and they announce to everybody like
what the deal is the entire novel is
just this one big long bloody like
roller coaster ride as all the guests
are like struggling to survive the night
so the rules are pretty simple all each
guest has to do is kill one other person
doesn't matter who it is if they kill
one other person then that guest will be
free to go although their memory of the
event is going to be wiped like with
some Pharmaceuticals like before they
leave so they can't tell anybody else
about this place now if they try to
escape the venue like if they try to go
outside the electronic bracelet on their
wrist will detonate which will blow
their arm off and there's also the
possibility that over the course of the
night even if like another guest doesn't
kill them then the bride and groom are
also within their rights to pick off
people as they see fit if they have a
good time or like enjoying themselves if
the mood strikes them which it does on
many many occasions so as I said this
concept is like pretty straightforward
pretty simple uh but it's just loads and
loads of real [ __ ] up fun and the
whole focus on Amy uh you know Amy's
ex-girlfriend Mariko and Amy's parents
really kind of like UPS the stakes
because you're really kind of like
rooting for them to find a way out of
this mess somehow uh now some of the
story too is told from Caleb's point of
view and those parts are kind of stomach
turning like I said because he gives off
a real in-cell Vibe like some Elliot
Roger type [ __ ] like the way he thinks
because his whole thing is even though
he it by all you know uh appearances he
has seemingly overcome his childhood
awkwardness like all the people picking
on him and bullying him and stuff like
that and has actually become a tech
billionaire like hence his ability to
afford this thing that he's is doing he
still keeps harboring these like
festering resentments against anyone who
slighted him even a tiny bit like in his
entire life and a lot of his perceptions
of things are really skewed or really
warped like of people's motives like he
thinks that people
um were picking on him like on purpose
when like they weren't even thinking
about it like it was just more
thoughtlessness he just thinks
everything is directed at him
um and Caleb has spent the last couple
of decades really apparently weaving
this narrative that his childhood best
friend Amy abandoned him so that she
could go chase boys that he felt were
inferior to him like I said very very
Elliot Roger
um the fact that she's a lesbian never
seemed to occur to him uh because it
seems as though he felt entitled to
because he was in love with her he felt
entitled to have his feelings for her
reciprocated and when they drifted apart
like as teenagers because she was kind
of like you know pursuing girls and
stuff like that and wasn't really
interested in romantic relationships
with men he perceived that as like oh
she abandoned me I wasn't cool enough
for her and stuff like that and he's
like been harboring this resentment this
whole entire time
and then like when he meets Lilith he
kind of found like a match made in hell
because Lilith is a lunatic she is just
like a stone cold psychopath and she was
very easily able to manipulate Caleb
into going all in on this Revenge
wedding
um by essentially like feeding his
feelings of entitlement and superiority
which she also shares um although to a
much greater degree like she's a lot
more extreme than he is but he's too
kind of cowardly to stand up to her
because and she knows how like how to
pushes buttons now though the venue uh
you know the novel is slightly lighter
on character development it's kind of
more focused on the unfolding Carnage
and like the action I actually didn't
really mind that one bit um I thought
the characters were sketched in just
enough like to keep the story
interesting and keep you pulling for the
good guys and also hoping that the bad
guys would get their comeuppance like in
the most Savage way possible like by the
end uh the main protagonist Amy was
actually like a particular highlight I
thought she seemed very much just like a
regular kind of messed up woman who was
you know kind of at a shitty place in
her life but relatable still
um but she gets thrust into this deadly
situation and is obviously like way out
of her depth but as the night goes on
she's kind of able to tap into hidden
reserves of strength in order to try and
save the day like save the people that
she loves so the venue I mean it's not
particularly deep or thought provoking
or anything like that but it doesn't
pretend to be anything other than what
it is which is this just great over the
top Darkly funny like bloodbath of a
novel that's just taking you on this
crazy Breakneck journey through a world
in which uh you know the ultra wealthy
like this guy Caleb can basically choose
to Stage their weddings or family
reunions or Gatherings or whatever as
barbaric fights to the death like let's
invite everybody we hate and make them
them like kill each other and a world in
which there are purpose-built venues
that will cater to their every whim in
that regard that will like do that for
them uh to be honest it pro it wouldn't
shock me uh if that turned out to be
true if some places like this did exist
that wouldn't shock me this latest uh so
you know so I'll know if I ever get like
an email invitation like some mysterious
invitation from somebody I barely
remember that like offers to fly me to
Europe for free like and with free food
and booze and stuff I think I'll I think
I'll turn that down like especially
after reading this one but yeah this is
super fun if you just want a really fun
gory Bloodbath
that you know it's just like a real
quick read very action-packed then this
is definitely definitely really really
fun I had a lot of uh fun with this one
so that'll do it for this tomes of
Terror and I will see you guys again on
the next one bye